the green fur the gyrating belly the
party horn knows this is philly fanatic
mascot for the philadelphia phillies
the philly's mascot is maybe the
wackiest of them all at least in the mlb
but it wasn't always that way
in the 1970s the phillies had
philadelphia phil and philadelphia
phyllis a pair of mascots straight out
of the 18th century and they were well
boring
so the phillies pivoted they
commissioned bonnie and wade two muppet
makers who had worked alongside puppet
mastermind jim henson
the phillies decided to create a
family-friendly attention-grabbing
mascot and on april 25th 1978 the philly
fanatic made his triumphant debut all
six feet of green fur made its way out
onto the field to roaring applause
[Applause]
38 years later the big green atv riding
super soaker wielding fanatic is still
making the crowds go wild
[Applause]
so all you phillies fans give it up for
the philly fanatic
[Music]
the city dubbed america's most dangerous
had its chicago is not the most
dangerous city in america camden new
jersey has that title on
life here in camden
is is dangerous life here in camden is
deadly
for every moment for every second that
the kids are out here playing they're
not getting shot at
[Music]
for every second that they're here
they're not witnessing something that
can get them hurt later on
the stakes are playing and right in
front of us
for kids that aren't participating
you know they're hustling
for kids that are participating in the
league
they're safe
[Music]
when i was a kid the expectation was
that you would play baseball
that pine point park would be a part of
who you were and what you did
[Music]
but by the time i'd become a teenager
there was this expectation that young
men my age would become the bread
earners by going out onto the corners
we were right in the midst of the crack
wars and so most of the young men that
had once played baseball were now on the
corners and most of the people that had
coach were now using
i dropped out of high school and began
dealing drugs like many of my
counterparts
i would eventually be arrested and
incarcerated and end up serving about
eight years in new jersey state prison
[Music]
when i came home it was truly with a
sense that i had to give something back
so
i came up with the idea of baseball
[Music]
baseball hadn't been played in camden
for almost two decades
but i knew that there was still a
connection here in this neighborhood and
here in this city
with the sport
so i said look if the city is going to
be crazy if the neighborhood's going to
be on fire let's try to create one safe
place for kids in the neighborhood and
let's start a baseball league
[Music]
hey joseph's brian just calling to see
if you had a
practice tonight with the softball
matter of fact i'ma text all the other
coaches and see who has practiced
tonight and who wants and who still
needs the catcher's gear okay cool all
right all right see you then thank you
when i started coming out and saying hey
we're gonna play baseball i used to get
people looking at me like i was crazy
but i had to be that leader and in many
instances i had to be fearless and be
the one willing to go up to ask the drug
dealer you know between these hours
would you mind not hustling
that's just what we had to do
and over time
the hustling fell by the wayside and
we became the norm in the park
there you go there you go
nice god college boy
when we started we ended up with 100
kids that year and it blew our mind
today we have over 650 kids playing and
that's kids playing from age 5 all the
way up to age 18.
if you set back and close your eyes you
just hear
the ping or the crack of the older kids
when they use their wood bats
the sound of the ball hitting leather
cleats scraping the gravel
kids rattling on the fence you know
cheering go batter batter batter
people used to yell and scream because
something was wrong and now people are
yelling and screaming because something
fantastic is happening
come game time
it's the most beautifulest thing in the
world
so daddy's going to teach you today how
to hit off the batting team all right
as a father who tells his daughter
constantly that you can do anything that
you want and be anything you want
you know you look up and and you want to
help me you remember why you're doing it
all right
good job ready
so much of our life in camden and so
much of our lives and our urban cores is
being hard
but kids for
the few hours that they're here they're
just free to act out and become whatever
hero they want to be
[Music]
they're just free
to laugh
[Music]
it's not always going to be easy and
there are forces at play that
they would love to see me fail
i have to continue to dig deep and
and put the grind in because
i just
i just know i got to do it come on
if i don't do it no one else is going to
do it
you know i tell myself there's plenty of
time to rest when i'm dead
[Music]
until then i'm going to live life to the
fullest
[Music]
for most of my life i was told that i
was never going to be able to throw a
curveball let alone pitch because of my
condition
looking back on it i just want to prove
people wrong
i just go up there i grab the ball and i
think to myself
i run this game
[Music]
growing up my mom my dad they wanted me
and my brother to play sports find
something that we love i got a lot of
stares and a lot of questions but for me
i was just like
yeah i was born with it like i don't
know any other ways is me
dylan has proteus syndrome
once a baby is born their body parts
never stop growing
in the first five years of his life he
had six surgeries but dylan's been able
to deal with those and adapt
in my case it was my fingers and my toes
i can't really move these three fingers
and then these two
i had issues that most people take for
granted like buttoning up a shirt the
sleeve ones those are the worst
he thinks that if you can do it he
should be able to do it and he figures
out how to do it
baseball's always been my favorite sport
but i've had some obstacles because i've
had to figure out how to catch because i
can't squeeze my glove and it's the same
thing with my curveball most people have
both fingers on it but i just use one
and i learned a new grip the way the
ball comes off of his middle finger and
ring finger he just gets a lot more spin
than normal people do it turns out
because of my condition i can throw a
curve ball that few other pitchers can
even though i wasn't the fastest pitcher
and i didn't have the greatest body for
pitching i always knew that i could
pitch because i was accurate and i could
hit my spots
when dylan came here as a freshman he
was never a guy that we thought was
gonna contribute as much as he did and
almost by accident he got his
opportunity
we were playing our rival school in the
second game of the year
and our pitcher was struggling
dylan was the only pitcher on the bench
and he threw three scoreless innings and
then we kind of knew at that point that
we had something after that my era was
the second best on the team
the highlight of the year for me was
when i came two outs shy of throwing a
no-hitter
a lot of people were surprised but i
knew that i could do it and it just
showed everyone that i'm a good pitcher
my family was always loving and said
just be you everything will work out
[Music]
when you think of wrigley first thing
come to your mind is the grass the
marquis out front and the sword board
it's like one of the main body parts of
wrigley field
i'm daryl wilson i'm a scoreboard
operator for chicago cubs
[Music]
i've been working at wrigley field since
1987.
wrigley phil is one of the oldest
ballparks besides boston it's been
around for over 100 years and
basically nothing has changed in the
school board since 1938
in the scoreboard we have at least three
guys and we're lucky four
while the cubs game is going on my job
is to post scores ending by inning and
pitching changes throughout the league
[Music]
once all the game starts in the
scoreboard it's it's pretty chaotic
you're writing scores down on your
clipboard and you're changing scores
while you're also
yelling at other guys to change their
scores and their games it's you know
it's hot it's very noisy the walkways
are a little narrow you got plates
numbers everywhere the switch out of the
scoreboard plate starts with a stiff
punch just just to pop it out of the
slots the plates are made of a lighter
thin metal you definitely have to latch
it we want to make sure that they're
locked in so if the wind's blowing out
they won't blow out at you or something
like that
you're running up and down and changing
scores for eight different games oh it's
definitely hard work
the view is outstanding it's it's just
like a 360 degree view of the entire
ballpark and the neighborhood and it's
like looking out to your backyard and
having the perfect lawn i mean that's
what it feels like you're walking around
you just feel
feel proud you know you're just proud of
your work and
the work that you guys put into it
the reason why i believe that the
scoreboard is special to fans because it
still keeps that old luster of the
old-time ballpark
i've seen a lot of modern parks but
wrigley field has an authentic original
feel of how baseball began
[Music]
you